he's Michael Rapaport actor/comedian
season 3 Netflix atypical please the
father of Sam a teenager on the autism
spectrum searching for love and
independence in fact Hootie and the
Blowfish were just here last hour and
they wanted to meet you at high praise
for a typical how are you I'm good I'm
good good to be here Dan I appreciate
that the love from Hootie and the
Blowfish yeah
probably not your kind of music though
not not my kind of music but I respect
them and their i reaiiy like Darius's
you know he's a big sports guy so I like
you know I've talked to him about sports
I want to say McLovin that that costume
was not just the way you looked in it
your your size the execution the
originality although all the praise and
accolades that it's gotten continues to
get post-halloween totally deserving
because when you see the Andy Reid video
yeah so he's 13 yeah and the same size
and he shows up for the punt pass and
kick contest this small kids are behind
him and McLovin came in and I go I don't
know who he is
and then it hit me and I went oh my God
he's Andy Reid as a 13 year old in the
punt pass next year he should be the
kids behind because that was that was
terrifying you think about like the scar
that left like they all thought I'm
gonna be and then that happens yeah when
did you realize you weren't gonna be in
the NBA I realized that wasn't gonna be
in the NBA I was 16 years old I was at
the iconic infamous 5 star basketball
camp Rex Chapman was was my camp
counselor and during a lecture or a
clinic from somebody I looked over at
Shawn Kemp NBA who is who is 17 or 18 a
time with a full goatee and he was 6
foot 9 and and I remember looking over
at him and I was like I'm it's it's not
gonna happen I mean the size of the guys
and this you know the gap I think around
15 changes for boys in sport the size
and the
it just goes from I was I was really
good 13 14 and then 15 you you go
outside of New York and you see 7-foot
16 year old and Shawn Kemp who I'm
looking at and like Shawn Kemp was as
good as he was when he played for the
Sonics and I was like this is so not
happened and I started thinking like
Plan B Plan B I was thinking about Diane
Williamson the other day you know we
always loved to do these comps and
everybody's always like Dominique
Wilkins and Charles Barkley to me
there's a little more Shawn Kemp in him
I think he's a little bit more raw than
then people are realizing and Shawn Kemp
to me could have been one of the great
players in the history of the game I
agree I think basketball came too easy
to him because he literally was that
good you know obviously I think you know
he wasn't he wasn't totally ready for
all the the hoopla of being an NBA
player I think there's a little bit of
draymond Green in Zion I don't think
he's LeBron I think that you know he's
uh I I don't think he's gonna be like
this guy who controls the ball I think
he's gonna do a lot of things off the
ball that are very good I think that
Zion Williamson will like a lot of these
players they will bet he'll benefit from
no hand checking you can't put your
hands on anybody and I get it's a new
era not tough but I feel like the NBA
because you don't like to do all these
throwback uniforms and where the old
jerseys when they wear the old jerseys
they should use like the old rules I
would just like to see and because
they're all great and I don't like to
compare because the errors they're all
great but I would like to see tre young
with a little hand checking on him I
would like to see LeBron being able to
be hand checked to slow these guys now
for a quarter you're gonna wear the
throwback uniforms let's do some
throwback rules
I mentioned Harden is a more polished
score than Michael Jordan now I agree
now Jordan of course would would have
developed a three-point shot now if I
was slaying now but what hardened uh I
get into an argument Doug Gottlieb all
the time because he says Kevin Durant's
a better score than James Harden because
I can put him on the post he can you
know he can shoot mid-range he can shoot
harden to me when he's on a roll is the
most unstoppable player in the game and
I'll put him up there with any
the great scores of all time I agree
because he got a handle he's got range
he's got size he can beat you to the
hoop and he's got a great step-back
three and I think his game is going I
think James Harden will be in the league
for twenty years because he's already
plays at his own pace he's not a high
jumper he is a deceptive first step but
because his herkie he almost plays like
an older guy now like he's so
herky-jerky and he's so off speed that
his game will age very well James Harden
will be in the league for a really long
time I don't think you know knock on
wood you don't want any of the players
to get injured but I don't think he'll
have if he ever does get injured I don't
wish on any player I think he'll be able
to come back and still be very James
Harden like because of the off-speed as'
of his game which is a will age very
well it's not like it's not a high
jumper he's not a dynamic speedster but
look just the way he handles the ball
and it keeps you off-balance especially
in this non hand checking era yeah it's
so much about the game Dan I didn't say
you did no I'm just saying I'd know it I
I like a guy who like to talk real but
real sport with because I could talk
trash Dan but I also know the game the X
is it they call me an X's and O's guy
who who's they just google it just say
Google and X's and O's Michael rap I'm
just throwing nothing because I said
this the last time I wasn't a longtime
fan longtime fan huge fan of yours dad
so I get a little juiced up when I come
here if I could have told you when you
saw the national title game between
Indiana State and Michigan State you saw
that in person yeah and if I said you
could buy stock in magic or buy stock
and Larry at the time because I learned
to shoot the jump shot I would have said
Larry who had a better NBA career man
that's neck and neck man that's that's
that's they both of them I think they
both bowed out early
they both bowed out early injuries they
I mean I don't know the statistics and
all that stuff
they were both it's kind of a tie they
were both sick
but for me in college because the blonde
hair and and literally Larry had got me
from shooting here to here seriously
when I saw him playing this is at the
time where you didn't watch
there was no replay I was nine so that
game came on and it was etched in my
memory those semi final games in college
came on it was etched in my memory that
changed my life
but the minute Larry Bird and I swear my
father is not one of these crazy New
Yorkers who like bred me to hate the
Celtics he we never discussed it it was
in my blood when he put that green
uniform on it was like God spoke to me
and said that's not a good person
anymore I swear to God like it's not
like I was bred like you know you're in
New York or we hate to it's like when I
saw him in that uniform for the Celtics
there was no more and I and I hated
Larry Bird but he changed my life
because him and magic but really him
because then I developed this over the
head left-handed jump shot iconic of
course um he just google it yeah go
google that was after you look a little
like you could be in the bird family the
best looking bird you look like you'd be
in the Brad Pitt family say okay like
you could be the best say that you're
the most handsome bird brother
thank you much putting oh then no it's
not the tell us about a typical a
typical season 3 yeah start airing today
it's been you know the show is a very
genuine sweet funny but also heartfelt
show about a dysfunctional functioning
family trying to figure out their lives
along with the fact that we have a son
who's autistic and it's really struck a
chord with with people of all ages and
from across the globe you know it's so
hard to do a show and to keep it on the
air for three seasons and and and this
show you know I've had people come up to
me and and and the way they respond to
it it's just so nice the character for
me I love playing him because he's so
he's so sort of
kind of repressed emotionally repressed
and he has a hard time articulating
himself and is by you could tell from
this interview here I don't Dan so I
loved I loved the character I love the
show and I just the response that people
have had to it has been he's been really
overwhelming to be honest with you I've
had you know just like from parents and
and and kids and it's a family show and
I'm very proud of atypical and and eight
season three just started streaming
today uh the day after Halloween the day
after McLovin one Halloween season three
of Netflix a typical and it's available
starting today when when you were on
friends yes and you were on what three
or four episodes I think it was four
okay so what do you remember about how
big a moment was that you know how big
how big was the show at the time the
show was huge I think it was the fourth
season so it was a maybe it was the
fifth season I don't remember but the
show was a huge success
um I knew some of the actors on it I
knew Schwimmer I knew Jennifer Aniston
she had just started dating Brad Pitt or
she went on to did they get married yeah
I think yeah they they they yeah they
got me I was at their wedding I remember
their wedding uh Brad because I had knew
Brad Pitt from true romance yeah there
was a literal like it was like a huge it
wasn't like a little plate there was
like a spread like enormous caviar thing
like a table of caviar and and I'm such
an animal I'm like you know I'm taking
it by the this is this is like Brad Pitt
and Jennifer and money's not an object
Billy Preston the late great bit
impressed and performed um they were all
super nice they were very successful
they couldn't have been more friendly
and and I enjoyed doing it you didn't
know the show I mean you knew it was a
hippy didn't know what would go on to be
this thing that keeps sort of being
Racine by children you know kids will
come up to me you're the guy from
friends you know like young kid all they
know is from the show and and you didn't
know that but you know is this
successful show so I had a good time
doing it love your name Gary Gary the
cop and I will say it's disappointing
that at the end
the day Phoebe played by the great Lisa
Kudrow she didn't choose Gary the cop
that was her gonna make out I think we I
think we kissed I don't think was like
making out cool your jets Dan okay it's
early in the morning link it Chloe you
have the video of rapper party making
out he's in for the real are you trying
to make out no no no no no I'm not
trying to make I follow the rules and
regulations dan like you know it said go
for a kiss and Gary kisses I just say
you know go nuts you know what I'm
saying because I I had to kiss somebody
in a movie how'd that work out for you
um I had a kiss Brad Pitt that's not bad
no it's not no it was Wendy Co V
McClendon oh yeah yeah from mother
Golders yes she's a good actress but I I
wasn't supposed to kiss her you just did
that
yeah but that's I feel like I'm a method
actor like I think you're good looking
then I just kiss you in the scene I
understand that can I say we since we've
mentioned Brad Google it's called acting
okay yeah it's callback Google um can I
tell you something last night for
Halloween I put on a jean jacket an old
faded jean jacket and I I thought my
costume was dope I had dressed up no one
knew what they were like Halloween you
know we're in a cosmic said I am this is
Hawaii I had my jean jacket on my hair
parted to the side and I said I'm Brad
Pitt from once upon a time in Hollywood
no one got it but I like the subtle
costume you know I had the sunglasses on
every no one sort of resemblance between
me and Brad Pitt for but if I close my
good eye yeah then I could maybe see you
as bread a little bit yeah a little bit
with the G I didn't wear the jean jacket
today because I didn't want to like as I
started look really really good and I
had the glasses and you're like that guy
is he too good-looking
now I don't think you're ever too
good-looking yeah I think you're too
good-looking if you're not an exact
Efron Zac Efron is not the actor Brad
Pitt pities yeah but he's still a pretty
guy very pretty but Brad Pitt has he's
proven himself to be a great act but
he's he he was so funny in that movie
excellent and people never talk about
Brad Pitt being funny and he was really
really funny of them funny and seamless
the acting was seamless
between him and DiCaprio seamless but he
doesn't try to and McLovin brings his
topic up like the term chewing up what
chewing up scenery obscene having a
conversation
he won't shut his mouth yeah you know
but yeah like chewing of scenery yeah
he's a great actor and and a great actor
is gonna play the the the tempo the way
it's supposed to be played and he did it
and DiCaprio did it in that in that film
I just saw the Irishman excellent
excellent
and De Niro Pacino and Pesci yeah but
they make it fun of my people like I and
I get tired of people picking on the
Irish take that up with those guys take
it up with Joe Pesci take it up with Joe
al and Bob and they're not even at there
they're Italian they're Italian yeah
well what do you want are you one of
these people Irish guy real mobsters why
did Sloane play a boxer's not a real
boxer that's the new trend you gotta
have like if you're playing a guy with
one leg we need we need one legged going
cut your leg off good yeah I get it
you're being disrespectful I get it he's
Michael Rapaport season three Netflix a
typical and it starts today and are you
out on the road for don't stand I am I
out on the road I appreciate that I'm
doing stand-up comedy I'm I'm going to
Portland and Sacramento and then I'm
going to Philly Boston all tickets are
available at Michael Rapaport comedy
calm but I'll be in Portland the big
redhead returns to Portland homage to
the great Bill Walton Michael Rapaport
comedy calm I'm looking for you think
you get a 32 Jersey go out on stage and
portly or little Grateful Dead music
let's do it and smoke up a little bit do
it Dan yeah let's do it the old like the
chunky neat knee brace I love Cortland
team it's one of the most selfless teams
I've ever seen
did you like did you cover those games
no but I was I was in college graduating
and they went down Oh to to the 76ers
George McGinnis the great doctor Jay
we'll be free will be free and I thought
oh my god cuz I had picked Portland to
win and my roommates were from Philly
and then Portland came back in one
fourth Street it was awesome I mean I've
only seen those games in the past but
those games and those personalities more
recently cos those were characters man
and I loved Walton I think Walton
understood the game as well as anybody
who's ever played it physically he
couldn't play it for a long period and
yeah that level but one of my favorite
teams all right good luck on the road
good luck with a typical and good luck
with your Knicks what dislike Gillick
good luck good luck good luck and I'm
gonna smack out the door like the Knicks
in Y okay good luck with your next key
luck with a typical good luck with your
your standard no I don't feel like I
feel like you're saying we'd good luck
with your stand-up and good luck with
your a typical that's genuine insincere
and then when you say good luck with
your Knicks it's like you're know you're
gonna punch me in the face are you right
you're right and you got my guy Willis
in well no I you got me you figured me
out I apologize it's tough being a
Knicks fan good luck with a tip I don't
care I don't want to talk about it good
luck with a good luck in your stand-up
comedy for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]